We've talked before about the problem that
we have in political discourse.
When one side doesn't accept facts, it is
a real impediment to being able to make progress
and have good faith debate about any issue
that we find important.
And we're seeing that now front and center
with the Ukraine fiasco where only 40% of
Republicans, 40% of Republicans believe that
Donald Trump spoke to the Ukrainian president
about Joe Biden on the phone.
Remember Donald Trump has admitted to this
that bogus transcript, which was actually
a memo, sort of a truncated summary of the
call, includes a discussion of Joe Biden between
Donald Trump and the Ukrainian president,
Ukrainian president.
So let's take a step back and think about
opinion versus fact.
If you pull people about something like their
opinion on gay marriage, it is far more reasonable
that you would have very different perspectives
from Democrats, Republicans, and now for me,
I think that the opinion on gay marriage,
there's only one right opinion on gay marriage,
but okay, this is a matter of opinion and
you would expect more difference in people's
opinion on gay marriage.
But when Monmouth university polling Institute
asked people, do you believe that Donald Trump
spoke about Joe Biden on that phone call with
a Ukrainian president?
Almost all Democrats believed that that is
something that was discussed.
About 60% of independence believed that it
was something that was discussed, but only
40% of Republicans believed it.
Donald Trump admitted that they discussed
this on the call.
Not only did Trump admit it when asked, but
the truncated transcript or memo that the
white house released also includes the mention
of Biden.
So what do we do?
What do we do when one side won't even accept
inconvenient but verified facts that their
own leader gives to them?
Now, of course, there's the separate question
of whether Donald Trump extorted or tried
to extort Ukraine.
And there's lots of other questions, but Trump
admitted that they spoke about Biden and 60%
of Republicans either don't believe it or
don't know.
Now there are some possible questions about
this poll.
It was conducted during a period mostly after
the transcript or memo was released, but there
was one polling day in there that was before
it was released.
Some people may just not have seen the news
about that yet.
Uh, but the trend is very clear.
If they don't like the facts, they pretend
they don't exist and this makes it difficult
or even impossible to advance serious conversations
about what has to be done.
It's similar with climate change where there
are real serious conversations about what
policies should we have, what degree of government
involvement should there be in a climate change?
And dealing with that.
What about personal responsibility when dealing
with climate change?
Whatever question you want to talk about,
we can't even get on the same page about what
the facts are because some large portion of
the American right wing just refuses to accept
the facts on climate change.
We can't possibly fix anything or even discuss
it in good faith.
If one side doesn't accept the facts, and
sadly this is how I end up back at, we need
to get around them to win.
We don't, we can't try to win with them.
A conversation about how to proceed with Trump
or about the economy or about who to vote
for in 2020 or about tariffs.
These conversations are pointless as ways
to engage with people about making change
in 2020 if they won't even accept basic facts,
including ones that their dear leader gives
them.
The short answer is you can't and you shouldn't,
and we don't need to as the upside.
I don't want to be a broken record again,
but half the country doesn't vote.
Meaning you don't have to go out and find
people and convince them that voting for Trump
is a bad idea.
That's not necessary to win this.
You just need to find people who are already
on our side and just explain to them the importance
of voting.
And that is much easier to do.
It's still not easy.
I've met people who don't vote, and it's not
easy to convince them that they should be
voting, but it is easier than convincing someone
who won't even believe Trump.
When Trump says, we talked about Joe Biden
on the Ukrainian president phone call.
Uh, and I don't even think that we should
bother doing it.